hi everyone thanks for joining me here
today it's a real pleasure to be able to
present this paper to you and I hope you
found it interesting
my job today is really to talk about the
ethical aspects of CRISPR um but I'm not
going to focused on the kind of more
traditional or standard ethical
questions around safety and risk and so
on I think those are interesting and
important questions to answer but there
are there is already a large discussion
going on around those things and some of
those are kind of technical questions
that I can't answer as an ethicist so
what I want to do is actually look at
CRISPR within a broader context and I'm
particularly going to be talking about
using CRISPR for germline modification
so I'm going to be talking about it in
the context of Human Reproduction
and I want to think about what CRISPR
will do in terms of how we think about
ourselves within that broader context so
what I'm going to do in my paper
hopefully is not answer the question is
the technology permissible or not that
seems to me as I said an important
question but not one that I'm going to
answer in this in this paper instead I
want to take a slightly broader focus
and ask what social and ethical effects
might this technology and its use have
so we might ask questions like what
future does it make possible and what
future does it close down what are the
opportunity cost of actually using
CRISPR to do germline editing of humans
what might it make us how might we think
about ourselves if we do use to remind
editing or what ethical relationships
what kinds of subjectivity Zoar into
subjectivities
does it foster or a row so broader
questions than just about risk so just
to give you a sense of the structure of
the paper I'm going to talk very very
briefly about what Chrismukkah 9 News
and then talk it Marling about how we
might put CRISPR
in its context of innovation in human
rhythm and try to get out why that's
important I want to look at for three or
four groups of people or objects that
actually matter for thinking about what
CRISPR does so I'm going to specifically
talk about scientists women children and
the technology is so and then I will
return to my broader questions about
ethical futures to conclude go on to
those sections what is Chris McKay
passed on by for this audience I don't
really need to give much isn't here so I
will just very briefly say that Chris
Burke s9 is often described as a kind of
pair of molecular scissors that
allowance for a double-stranded break
that you can then delete or insert a
gene to actually change the genome of a
human being of course it can be used
both for somatic and germline gene
editing somatic being related to the
body cells of a particular individual
the germline being the kind of editing
that would happen in the context of
human reproduction where any changes
made are then inheritable by the future
generation so just to give you a very
short history of Chrismukkah 9 so CRISPR
itself was discovered in 1997 by
scientists at Osaka University and in
the ensuing 20 years there are a lot of
important a lot of important discoveries
made but the important breakthrough from
the point of view of germline editing
well it's the discovery or the
refinement in 2012 of the CRISPR Katz 9
system by Jennifer Doudna in a manual
Charpentier that refinement gave rise to
as you know a lot of issues around
patents an ongoing debate and legal
battle around patent issues it also gave
rise to various international various
calls for international moratorium on
germline genome editing genome editing
including
at the moment there's still no
international consensus on the safety
efficacy or acceptability of using
Chrismukkah 9 - germline genome edit
human beings even so you will know that
in 2018 there was an enormous
controversy when a Chinese scientist
announced that he had in fact use genome
editing in the birth of - young - baby -
do baby girls in China and more recently
in 2019 a Russian scientist also
announced plans for more crisper babies
saying I think I'm crazy enough to do it
which is hardly reassuring it's the kind
of situation we're now in no
international consensus and yet all your
doctors of the technology already taking
it up using it in human reproduction so
for me I think it's really important to
think about what affects that early
adoption of the technology will have in
how we think about the ethics of
germline genome editing and whether we
go forward with it or not so you all
know the Chinese controversy arose
around a Chinese physicist taejeong q
when he announced in 2018 by a huge dude
even at a conference in Hong Kong that -
two girls had born following the use of
CRISPR
he used CRISPR to target the ccr5 gene
which is known as an HIV infection
pathway he did this because the
biological father of the girls is HIV
positive
however standard practices for
preventing paternal transmission of HIV
in conception were used in the IVF that
wasn't there for the birth of both girls
and after those standard procedures
there's really no risk of transmission
in conception the case was controversial
for a number of reasons I mean one
because the
were provided with free IVF if they
agreed to CRISPR rating some serious
questions around consent and inducement
and so on
it's also been controversial because
it's emerged that several scientists in
the US and UK knew that jeongsu was
planning to do this and didn't do
anything to prevent it happening it also
seems that the standard processes for
clearance were not followed and there's
quite a bit of concern obscurity around
exactly what happened in that case so
the ensuing debate around the
controversy has focused on concerns
about safety that therapeutic necessity
you've actually of the intervention
given that there are already well-known
and efficacious ways of preventing HIV
transmission and the transmission risk
from the father would feel it was
minimal and there's also significant
concerns around the consent procedure
and questions of inducement now I think
those questions are all important and
necessary to concede on but what they do
is narrow our focus on to that
particular case and when they do that we
lose the broader focus and thinking in
terms of thinking about what the uptake
of CRISPR actually need in that case so
what we can say is that PageRank you
took away the possibility of a world
without genome edited children that is
simply no longer possible now that we
have to gene editing children in
existence and the fact that we have
those two children means that it's much
more likely that we will also have more
so in a sense paycheck you forces into a
particular future and close down the
opportunity of another without any kind
of global consensus around whether the
futures were desirable or not so I think
it's in that frame that we need to think
about what the early uptake of crispix
s9 might do
so in order I should get at this
question I want to take a step back and
put CRISPR in context a bit more because
while on the one hand what hey Jake you
did was quite radical on another hand
he's actually following a fairly
well-worn pathway which is the pathway
of early uptake and innovation in human
reproduction so with frontier scientists
kind of using a technology before there
is any consensus about whether that
technology is safe or not so that's the
context I want to look at the use of
Chris because 9in so just to kind of
give you a sense of that history and the
context that I'm talking about what I
have in mind is the history of
scientists and their breakthrough babies
so scientists frontier scientists kind
of stepping ahead of international
debate to actually use technologies to
produce children so what I have in mind
we have here images of Robert Emmet in
the first test you baby with the advent
of IVF in 1978 John Zhang and the first
three parent baby using mitochondrial
replacement techniques that baby was
born in Mexico in 2016 and then Paige
thank you and the first two CRISPR
babies born in 2018 now these pictures
have just taken up the web they're
fairly random but there's one striking
feature of these and that is that the
mother is nowhere to be seen
now of course there are good privacy
reasons for there but I think it's also
kind of interesting so many objects to
know that we have scientists and their
breakthrough babies and the mothers who
are actually unnecessary theory we still
require pregnancy for babies for
instance obscured within the thinking of
what's actually happening in the advent
of reproductive innovation so I guess
the question what are the frameworks
that we can use to answer the question
of how we get from a
the is a framework of responsible
innovation responsible translation
because it's not really the innovation
itself that's problematic with the way
in which innovations are taken up within
the clinical context of Human
Reproduction
so it's that translation aspect that's
particularly interesting so how do we
think about responsible translation well
I've been digging around in the
literature on responsible translation
and innovation I came across one paper
that I found particularly interesting
and it's interesting because it really
stands out of the concerns around safety
and so on and this paper argues that
responsibility for the responsibility in
translation or innovation is necessarily
a responsibility of the future it helps
to create it claims that responsibility
for innovation is a condition of mutual
vulnerability because of the kind of
creatures we are so the claim there is
that by virtue of being human we are
vulnerable vulnerable that's the nature
of what it is to be human and you can
think about this in terms of the fact
that we are all vulnerable so we almost
to accident to misfortune we're
vulnerable to each other and so on so
vulnerability is a key feature of what
we are as humans so this this framework
is suggesting that the key terms for
thinking about responsible translation
are actually things like Futurity and
vulnerability and intersubjectivity the
kind of relationships that we have with
each other in the context of translation
of innovative technologies so to get why
it might be useful to actually think
about those terminologies in responsible
translation I want to actually look at
the various actors or actresses that we
might identify in the process of
translation and think about what they do
and how they might be affected by the
translation of innovative technologies
and the first of these is scientists or
clinicians
no it's not there we go so the question
is why do they do what they do and what
happens to them when they are these kind
of frontrunner scientists in particular
I think the first thing to know is that
scientists frontier scientists in
particular a world makers who operate in
a multi dimensional context and by world
makers I mean that they actually
contribute to shaping the life world or
the shared life world that we operate in
as human beings they shape our social
context in important what angles now
there are of course a number of
different pressures operating on
scientists that motivate them to act in
particular ways they're valued
scientific and institutional pressures
the necessity to impact the importance
of getting grant funding and so on so
all of those factors actually contribute
to shaping the motivations of scientists
themselves there's also the broader
context of the of the precarity of
research science employment I'm not sure
how it is elsewhere but in my context
the site the employment of the research
scientist in a university is often very
dependent on research funding for
instance so there's a certain kind of
precarity involved in in science
employment increasingly I think there's
also significant commercial drivers
operating in science so this is if we go
back to the history of CRISPR the the
patent battle that emerged around the
refinement of the CRISPR calf 9 system a
very indicative of the importance of
commercialization and the capacity to
monetize any invention and so on so
those are really strong motivators I
think in the context of science today
there are also of course just the the
personal motivations of individual
scientists it may be that sometimes has
had just driven by the
to be the first it may be that they are
driven by other motivations like the
desire to please their father we don't
necessarily know what individual
motivations are but they are certainly
there and part of the picture of this
multi-dimensional context I think one
thing to note about this context is the
way in which the the role of the
scientist has become merged with the
roles of clinicians but also of
entrepreneurs scientists themselves are
increasingly required to be
entrepreneurial and you can see that
kind of strong entrepreneurial ISM
coming out with some of our breakthrough
scientists that I mentioned before
so John Zhang for instance is very much
of this kind of scientist clinician
entrepreneur type figure and we also
need to talk think about what risks what
rewards and what repercussions there
might be for scientists right at the
acting right at the frontier of
translation so certainly there was some
risks for hay junk you and some of those
have been borne out in terms of the the
after effects of his his use of CRISPR
but presumably there may also be some
rewards or at least he's motivated by
the perception that there are
significant rewards to be had from being
that kind of frontrunner scientist so
the point there in relationship
scientists and clinicians is that it is
a multi-dimensional context with a lot
of different pressures acting on
scientist motivating them to be right at
the forefront of translation now what
about the women as I said before they're
really not part of the picture of the
scientists and their breakthrough babies
but they're still essential to
scientific innovation and translation in
the sphere of human reproduction so here
we need to think about who the women are
and what they do and here I think we can
that women lend themselves through the
kind of translational process by giving
these early adoption of technologies
like CRISPR a certain kind of maternal
of borodin and sorry Tracy my computer
yeah so the second group of people we
need to think about are women so women
are really central to the process of
scientific innovation and translation
today especially in the sphere of human
reproduction they're still necessary
because we haven't yet got past
pregnancy and they're essential because
it seems to me that the that the
involvement of women in this process
actually lends some legitimation and
authority to it so we can say that
there's a kind of maternal Authority in
the fact that a woman house herself
agreed to use this technology to have
her children now interestingly an
anthropologist by the name of Reina wrap
came up with the idea of Moral
pioneering in reproduction some years
ago in the context of thinking about
prenatal testing technologies but I
think we can see that this concept is
really pertinent here because women who
are using these technologies are really
right at the forefront of the kind of
moral debates of whether these
technologies are acceptable or not so
they're very much kind of moral pioneers
in terms of the translation of
innovative technologies so it seems
clear to me that women are actually part
of the legitimation process for
innovative technologies but here I want
to be clear that women are neither
hoodwinked nor intentionally lending
themselves to legitimate these
technologies instead I would say
using a quote from the French
philosopher Michel Foucault that people
know what they do frequently they even
know why they do what they do but what
they don't know is what what they do
does and that's a very cute way of
saying that people don't know what the
consequences of their actions may be or
what the effects of their actions may be
so the last point that I want to make
about women is that maternal and
parental desire itself acts as a driver
of innovation so we couldn't say this
because scientists often point to the
importance of reproduction and the
strength of that maternal or parental
desire in terms of legitimating their
use of technology but we also need to
know that the that desire itself is not
straightforward because the desire and
the technology are themselves
co-produced the desire is not
pre-existent to the technology nobody's
sitting around 10 years ago saying I'd
really like to genome edit my child it's
only when the technology becomes
possible that the desire of cell becomes
pertinent and actually starts to drive
that that process of translation so what
about the children who are they and how
do they live so interestingly when we
talk about the children of innovative
technologies there are two things that
we need to keep in mind on the one hand
what we're talking about is the figure
of the future child the child not yet in
existence but who might come into the
existence if we are able to use these
technologies so in that sense the child
is a kind of prolific target of
responsibility they're a target of
responsibility that does not yet exist
but we should also keep in mind that we
are talking about actual children that
will exist or do exist so if we think
about the history of IVF for instance we
think about the children who have been
born of that technology and in
particular the first child born of that
technology
what is it like then to be a
breakthrough baby what kind of life does
one lead as a breakthrough baby now
Louise Brown the child born the first
child born of IVF often kind of
downplays the importance of or the
effect of being a breakthrough baby on
her life but we might note that not
everyone has their 40th birthday at the
British Museum and has it broadcast in
the international press so there's
clearly some difference to the lives of
breakthrough babies there might also be
different moral responsibilities that
the children of innovation have by
virtue of their experimental black birth
would they for instance be obliged to
submit to ongoing medical testing to
making their lives public and so on
because that's how we will know if these
technologies are actually safe or not we
can't prove we can suggest that perhaps
they have an obligation to not reproduce
because really that's the only way that
we will be sure that the technology is
safe
we won't know whether it's safe for the
next generation or not until that next
generation comes along so we might also
say then that there in fact obliged to
reproduce because that's the only way
that we will know that the technology is
safe so it may be that the children of
experimental birth actually have certain
kinds of responsibilities or obligations
by virtue of that birth now the last
thing I want to talk about are the
technologies themselves what do the
technologies themselves actually do in
the process of translation well there
are a few things to say but the first of
these is that technologies make possible
other other technologies that are
neither intended nor foreseen so if we
think about in vitro fertilization for
instance no one imagined when that was
being developed that it would give rise
to other technologies such as
pre-implantation genetic diagnosis that
was just not part of the picture
and yet PGD is only possible because i
it is possible we can also say that
technologies have social effects that
may not be foreseen or intended so using
IVF it's an example again no one foresaw
that I've yet would give rise to a
system of international commercial
surrogacy or could give rise and yet
that's what it's done it's made possible
certain kinds of international
commercial surrogacy arrangements so
what also comes from that is that
technologies make some forms of social
existence possible and put others into
question so when we think about IVF
again and gamete donation that process
of IVF and the possibility of using
donated gametes has really put into
question the importance of genetic
relatedness in a way that four years ago
just wasn't questioned at all now I'm
not saying that
prior to IVF all families were based on
genetic relatedness that that's clearly
not true but the way in which we thought
about genetic relatedness was very
different from how we think about it now
so given those things we think the
question to ask is what might genome
editing doing what kinds of other
technologies might it give rise to what
social effects may enhance and what
forms of social existence may it make
possible and what forms of social
existence may render impossible in other
words what are the opportunity costs of
using CRISPR case nine because
everything has opportunity costs any
Avenue of action will have an
opportunity cost so what are the
opportunity cost of using CRISPR cash
nine from the germline genome editing so
this takes me back to my concluding
slide which is and returning us to the
question of ethical features so I want
to emphasize that the point that I've
made is that the context of translation
in human reproduction is very
multi-dimensional there are a lot of
different pressures coming into play
there are a lot of different actors and
actors with different effects and
implications and power and so on I
haven't given an exhaustive list of what
those actors are here I've just given a
small selection of what they might think
we also might think about institutional
review boards for instance what effect
do they have what do they do within the
process of translation but I won't again
push home my central point that
responsibility associated with
innovation is necessarily responsibility
for the future and helps to create in
the process of taking up any particular
technology or using a particular
particular technology we create certain
futures and render others impossible and
this reminds us of the centrality of
intersubjectivity
and vulnerability in the process of
translation translation is about a
shared world as much as it is about
individual desires and interests so in
relation to genome editing I think we
must think what it is that we are doing
that is what world are we creating for
future generations not just for us but
for our children and our children's
children thank you